a crowd at a trump rally chance to send
comically villainous anti-american
congresswoman Ilhan Omar back to her
native country the usually excitable
suspects lose their minds on the left
right and center meanwhile President
Trump has already disavowed the chant we
will cut through the hysteria and
examine why not only should we not send
Omar back we should make her Speaker of
the House then the UK's Prince Charles
predicts the end of the world in just
bum-bum-bum 18 months and Berkeley
outlaws sexist words like manhole
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
no more manholes it's 2019 people come
on we've got to get to the biggest news
the bigot not just the biggest news of
the day the biggest news of the century
the biggest news in the history of
American politics people at a trump
rally chanted send her back to a an
awful villainous anti-american
congresswoman and then President Trump
disavowed the remarks but this is the
biggest news it's awful it's the Third
Reich if Nazism the left right and
center people are losing their minds
over this chant because nobody has any
sense of proportion anymore in politics
and everybody is extremely excitable so
what happened in the in the rally
President Trump went after Ilhan Omar as
well he should have because she's
singularly awful and she's anti-american
it all started out well we'll show you
what she or what he said rather but
first I have got to tell you about net
suite and how important it is for you to
know your numbers about your business
I've been a part of a lot of companies
that have started up brand new companies
like The Daily wire for one but also a
few other companies and one of the
biggest problems that keeps people from
knowing their numbers from actually
digging into the hard numbers of their
business is they have this hodgepodge of
business systems this is where NetSuite
comes in really handy
NetSuite by Oracle is the business
management software that handles every
aspect of your business in an
easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you need to
grow so what happens I know this because
I've been a part of a lot of businesses
that we're just starting and you just
start using these different systems
maybe you have some familiarity with
this system and someone recommends this
system and sooner or later all of your
numbers are being run by totally
disparate systems that aren't talking to
each other which wastes time it wastes
money it gives you a lot of unneeded
headaches well thankfully thanks to
NetSuite you can manage your sales
finance accounting orders HR instantly
right from your desktop or phone that's
why NetSuite is the world's number one
cloud business system don't handicap
your business use the best right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles KO w l es
that is NetSuite comm slash Knowles KO w
l es to download your FREE guide let me
tell you something when I've been
involved in businesses that we're
starting up we could have saved a lot of
time time is money we could have saved a
lot of money too if we had just used
NetSuite it is great and you have
nothing to lose right now by downloading
your free guide seven key strategies to
grow your profits go to NetSuite dot-com
slash Knowles canna wles
give your business the best so Trump
goes after L ha no more as he should
have it started out very well here's
what he said some people did something I
don't think so some people did something
yeah some people did something all right
she pleaded for compassion for Isis
recruits attempting to join the
terrorist organization she was looking
for comfort
Omar left that American speak of al
Qaeda in a menacing tone and remarked
that you don't say America with this
intensity you say al Qaeda makes you
proud al Qaeda makes you proud you don't
speak that way about America
and at a press conference just this week
when asked whether she supported
al-qaeda that's our enemy that's our
enemy they are a very serious problem
that we take care of but they always
seem to come along somewhere she refused
answer she didn't want to give an answer
to that question all completely true so
far so good he should campaign on this
until until Election Day in 2020
absolutely right then and this is the
this is what has everyone losing their
minds heads exploding the crowd briefly
chanted send her back here's the crap
now if you can't see the clip you got a
look at Trump's face here usually when
he hears these chants lock her up USA
make America great again he's got a big
beaming smile he's encouraging and he's
saying it too
not the case with this chant in this
chant he actually looks a little angry
he's got this frown he's not budging a
muscle he's not in toning anything he's
not encouraging it which is important
when you see his reaction to it this
morning so according to the mainstream
media the left even many conservatives
and I'm specifically talking about those
conservatives who all they want to do is
prove to the left that they're not
racist or sexist or bigoted or this
phobic or that phobic that's all they
want they just all they want is to make
sure the New York Times doesn't say
anything mean about them according to
these people this is the single most
horrific event in American history it
doesn't it doesn't get any worse than
this it forget about slavery Jim Crow
the Dred Scott decision
forget about terrorist attacks forget
about the wars that we've no Pearl
Harbor no no this is the worst event
because a crowd briefly chanted send her
back to an immigrant who speaks with
sympathy of al Qaeda everybody needs to
take a breath Justin Amash the former
Republican who wants to impeach Trump
and he left the GOP he was tweeting out
all of this hysteria this morning I just
responded to him I said calm down
so okay take a breath ah first thing
Ilhan Omar is a comically villainous
figure in politics she giggles about Al
Qaeda she equates al Qaeda with the
United States and England and the US
Army she equates al Qaeda terrorists
with US soldiers laughs about it on
camera she begged a judge to give
leniency to Isis terrorists she's one of
only a couple legislators to vote
against denying insurance benefits to
the families of terrorists
she explicitly refused to condemn al
Qaeda at a press conference this week
and that's all apart from the regular
jew-hatred that she spouts that's not
even taking into account the the things
she has tweeted about al-qaeda and Jews
in America that's just what she's or
rather other things that she's tweeted
about Israel and Jews in America that's
just talking about what she said about
Al Qaeda Isis and terrorists
it is perfectly understandable why
people would want to send her back a
perfectly understandable passion also
the chant is ugly it's not a nice chant
we don't want to see that in America
send her back to immigrants who were US
citizens and it's politically
counterproductive those things can be
true at the same time it can be totally
understandable the impulses she can be
completely villainous and awful and also
that chant is ugly and we don't like it
and it doesn't ring very nicely in
America and politically it's
counterproductive to the people who are
chanting it well here's the good news
folks President Trump has already
disavowed the chant as well he should
here's President Trump this morning
chanting send her back well number what
I think I did I started speaking very
quickly and it really was a loud I
disagree with her by the way
but it was quite a chant and I felt a
little bit badly about it but I will say
this I did and I started speaking very
quickly but it started out rather rather
fast as you probably noticed so tell
your supporters I disagree with it there
it is simple simple as can be you know
that the thing that the mainstream media
in the left and the anti-trump
conservatives just the the minute that
any news story could possibly reflect
poorly on Trump they pounced on it they
love it they it's like their favorite
thing they say this is actually the only
time conservatives do pounce the
conservatives generally don't pounce
despite what the mainstream media said
but some anti Trump conservatives do Pat
the minute a syllable leaves Trump's
mouth or one of his supporters mouths
they take to Twitter they say the worst
thing that's ever happened in the
history of the world it's okay it was an
ugly chant it it is the sort of thing we
do
want to hear in America and Trump
disavowed it
why didn't you disavow it in the moment
well what is Trump gonna do in the
moment he's gonna say don't ever say
that he what basically what they want is
this moment that John McCain had in 2008
which where he tells his supporters that
they're awful in their bigots with the
left ones is for Republicans to campaign
like twice failed presidential candidate
John McCain that's what they keep saying
John McCain was just trending on Twitter
why can't Republicans campaign like the
twice failed presidential candidate John
McCain oh I can't imagine why you'd want
us to campaign like that so he didn't
Trump didn't humiliate his supporters he
didn't insult his supporters in the
moment he did pick up the speech he
didn't participate in it and then this
morning he said I didn't like it I
disagreed with it I felt kind of bad
about it great way to handle it you're
not setting yourself up in opposition to
your supporters you're sort of gently
chiding them and making clear you don't
want it to happen again great that's
wonderful what does the chant really
mean and we'll get to that in a second
but first rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer we're talking about
safety we're talking about all the
dangers that are out there in the
society so you should make sure that
your home is safe you probably already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you will get an
alert and be able to see hear and speak
to them all from your phone which is
thanks to the two-way video and two-way
audio features on ring devices you know
I travel around a fair bit and so
sometimes sweet little ELISA is in that
apartment all by her lonesome now
fortunately she is a very good shot and
she's got a great right hook but I feel
safer because of ring ring allows you to
keep tabs on your home wherever you are
I can do it from the studio I can do it
from some college campus or some
speaking event I've got on the other
side of the country I could do it from
the moon I bet if we ever go back to the
moon on this 50th anniversary of Apollo
11 a you you can just do it from
anywhere you feel like you're in the
Jetsons I mean you feel like you're just
living in the future it's an
extraordinarily inexpensive great value
way to keep keep track of what's going
on at your doorstep
whether it's a robber whether it's a
delivery man whether it's your
mother-in-law I don't know which one you
fear more so make sure that you get it I
mean it is just incredible technology it
is it it's better than the neighborhood
watch it's better than having those old
clunky security systems it's just a
fabulous piece of equipment as a
listener right now you have a special
offer on a ring starter kit with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
camera the starter kit gives you
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home go to
ring comm slash Knolls that is ring.com
slash Knowles get it now you are going
to absolutely love it so go check it out
feel like you're in the Jetsons and keep
your sweet little honey safe just like
we keep sweet little Alisa safe so this
is good it seems like the this seems
like the right thing president Trump
rightly attacked
Ilhan Omar his supporters some of his
supporters went too far they chanted
something ugly and politically
unproductive he gently rebukes them for
it alright good it's over this all
happened within the span of what 10
hours great now what does the chant mean
I don't think anyone is really calling
on her to strip her of her citizenship
and deport her I think people are
expressing their frustration that we
have an anti-american terrorist
apologist in the US Congress and that's
a real a real frustration I also suspect
very few people actually want to give
the President of the United States the
authority to strip citizens of their
citizenship and deport them at will so
what the statement is doing is
expressing moral disapproval of Ilhan
Omar's egregious actions and a lot of
people are being disingenuous here
though the Washington Post tweeted out
last night they said quote Trump's
accusation is that rep Omar sympathizes
with al Qaeda terrorists we found no
evidence for that claim fortunately I
have found no evidence for the claim
that the Washington Post is a credible
newspaper I did however find evidence of
Ilhan Omar expressing sympathy for al
Qaeda and speaking a very strange and
giggly way about Al Qaeda here's the
evidence the thing that was interesting
in the class was every time
the professor said okay that he sort of
like his shoulders went up and you know
commanded al-qaeda you don't say America
with an intensity you don't say England
with intensity you know you don't you
don't say the army with an intensity car
though care was founded after 9/11
because they recognized that some people
did something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties you respond to some of the
president's specific claims most notably
that you're a communist and that you're
Pro al-qaeda I think it is beyond time
it's beyond time to ask Muslims to
condemn terrorists we are no longer
going to allow the digna fication of
such ridiculous ridiculous statement
hey Washington Post I found your
evidence also I mean this isn't on video
this is just in the newspapers Ilhan
Omar asked for leniency for terrorists
she voted to let terrorists families
keep insurance money for from their
terrorist family members and she almost
certainly committed immigration fraud by
marrying her brother so she's absolutely
awful the conservatives pretending that
this is the worst thing that's ever
happened also were being disingenuous
here President Trump didn't lead the
chant he didn't participate in the chant
he didn't encourage the chant chant was
over quickly and then he disavowed the
chant it's fine it's ugly it's bad it
thing that's so counterproductive about
it is it almost makes her sympathetic
which is virtually impossible to do
because she's so villainous so that
should be discouraged where Trump bears
responsibility here I mean I thought he
handled the chant and the aftermath as
well as he possibly could have where he
bears some responsibility is he could
have avoided this almost certainly by
being more precise in the wording of his
tweet so he sent out that tweet and said
instead of saying if you don't love
America leave America which is the
sentiment he was more or less expressing
instead he said
that these four women he was implying
that these four women should go back to
their home countries even though three
of them are from America and so if the
tweet had said America love it or leave
it go spend time in countries that
aren't so great come back here and then
tell us why why our countries is even
worse that would have worked so he's the
leader he he started this meme of
dissenter back now he's dealing with the
fallout of that and he course-corrected
he did course-correct but he's got to
keep hammering that home and he does
bear some responsibility and it it
should give him pause just just not to
create the political headache for
himself of maybe way to be you know you
you write out the tweet it looks like a
really good tweet just double-check it
just hit it from a few more angles try
to be a little bit more precise because
if he had been a little more precise in
his language this would have been a
knock out political attack and it I
think it's still fine I don't think the
sky is falling but it just could have
been he could have made it easier for
himself also and this is the point I
want to drive home to the people who had
been chanting we don't want to send her
back we we don't she is the greatest
gift to conservatives it's not even
since aoc she's a greater gift to
conservatives than aoc because a OC just
kind of seems like a buffoon in some
ways she's sort of sympathetic because
she seems unintelligent Ilhan Omar
doesn't seem unintelligent she just
seems wicked and she giggles about al
Qaeda and she equates Muslim terrorists
with US soldiers I mean that is a
there's no comparison there so we
shouldn't send her back we should make
her the Speaker of the House we should
make her the leader of the Democrats for
life we should make every Democrat rally
behind her which was the effect of the
tweet that Trump sent in the first place
we should encourage that now speaking of
the sky actually falling I have to get
two really bad news coming out of the
United Kingdom and the royal family but
first this Saturday marks the fiftieth
anniversary since we put a man on the
moon and there is an incredible new
podcast app by esoteric radio theater
called Apollo 11 what we saw this thing
immediately shot to number three on the
iTunes Apple podcasts chart
a week later it's still in the top ten
so they just released Episode three in
the beginning it is out now the host is
our pal bill Whittle author pilot and
space enthusiasts and he takes you on
the journey of what it took to get to
the moon and what happened once we got
there it's a great story and it also
also tells you how things almost went
horribly wrong so head over to Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts and subscribe today to Apollo
11 what we saw an incredible way to
commemorate the 50th anniversary of the
moon landing this Saturday do you
remember when a OC told us six months
ago that we only had 12 months left to
live like the world is gonna end in 12
years if we don't address climate change
and your biggest issue is your your
biggest issue is how are we gonna pay
for it and like this is the war this is
our world war two okay so this is a
world war two this is the end of the
world in 12 years
according to Prince Charles this
situation is way worse according to
Prince Charles AOC was off by 10 and a
half years actually we only have 18
months left before we reach a tipping
point and the world cannot be saved
Prince Charles just recently said this
quote I'm firmly of the view that the
next 18 months will decide our ability
to keep climate change to survivable
levels and to restore nature to the
equilibrium we need for our survival now
this is particularly bad news because in
2015 just four years ago Prince Charles
said that we had 35 years left before we
reached that tipping point so I don't
know what happened in the past four
years but apparently things have gotten
way WAY worse and we should note in
Charles's defense the 35 years
prediction only came after his 2009
prediction where he warned that we only
had 100 months left to save the planet
which by that measure means that we
passed the point of no return in 2017
which means that there's nothing we can
do anymore which means I guess we should
probably just live it up because the
world is already doomed it's that right
something like that no because now we
have another 18 months I wonder how much
more time we'll have in 18 months when
the world
doesn't end in Prince Charles tells us
we have another 10 months or another 10
years or who knows it's almost as if all
of these alarmist warnings are arbitrary
and disingenuous emotional manipulation
to try to affect the same leftist
policies that these people have been
pushing for a hundred years most of
which have nothing to do with the
environment they have been doing this
for ever here is what the left does they
tell everyone that the world is about to
end then they tell everyone that luckily
they have the one solution that can
prevent the world from ending and then
they tell everyone that because there's
just there's really no time left we just
have to embrace their solution without
asking any questions without thinking
about it too much and then that's the
only way we can save the world but if we
wait and we think about it
then the world is going to end we have
to do it really really quickly
I remember this watching an inconvenient
truth that out war movie in 2006 even I
watching that movie when he came to the
end he said whole world's gonna end but
it's not too late we still have like
five seconds to do something as long as
you do exactly what I tell you to do
that's what they always end it with that
we can still do something as long as you
embrace exactly what I want right now
and even I walked out of there thinking
gosh maybe maybe he's right maybe I
don't know I mean what was I was 16 at
the time I was I was emotionally
manipulated by that movie it which is
what they are all doing the left wants
us to adopt these policies quickly
because they don't want us to think
about them most of the green New Deal
has nothing to do with the environment
it's about redistributing wealth to
Native American tribes what does that
have to do with the environment it's
about exploring reparations so what does
that it has nothing to do with the
environments of a universal socialist
health care again nothing to do with the
environment but we have to do it quickly
because if we reflect on the policies
will realize that we're being scammed so
I can't let us reflect on them the other
reason we have to do it quickly is
because if we think about it long enough
we'll remember that all of their other
doomsday predictions didn't come true
right 20 so now we have 18 months 2015
we had 35 years 2009 we had only 100
months which he means the world past the
tipping point in 2017 but no it didn't
really we got some extra time or we got
an extra what three three and a half
years something about we got to do it
now every one of these Al Gore said New
York City would be completely underwater
by now didn't happen
Florida would be completely underwater
by now didn't happen none of these
things the population bomb in the 1970s
if we don't dramatically stop decrease
the world's population abortion
contraception if we don't do that then
we're all gonna die we're wealthier
today than we than any time in history
way wealthier than we were in the 1970s
and we have way way more people it was
just totally debunked remember in the
70s global cooling was going to lead to
a new new ice age unless we embrace
their policies now global warming is
going to lead to a new hell on earth
unless we embrace their policies how
many times have they been proven wrong
so I have a deal if they ever are proven
right on their predictions on their
doomsday prophecies then maybe I'll
start to listen to them then maybe I'll
start to worry until then not so much
think is speaking of things by the way
even crazier than Prince Charles's
doomsday predictions the City of
Berkeley is banning gendered language
from government of course it's happening
in Berkeley California no policemen only
police officers no Chairman only Cher
people no manpower you can't no way can
you say manpower only human effort
that's the new politically correct term
no manholes now it's maintenance holes
frankly I think main maintenance is a
little too close to man for my liking
but I guess as a progressive step in the
right direction no more he or she they
won't use pronouns anymore singular
pronouns in the Berkeley City government
only the singular they like they is
drinking from the leftist here's tumblr
they likes tears that's what we've
reduced our language to this is
significant the council member they're a
rigel I think that's how you pronounce
his name I don't know Rigel Robinson
said
there's power in language this is a
small move but it matters and he's
absolutely right he's being completely
honest these little small moves in
language matter a lot that's why the
left fights so hard to change them
that's why there are 0.2% of the
population if that is confused about
their biological sex and we've spent
years now debating whether we can say he
or she or we have to use the singular
they which is an assault on the English
language because it radically changes
our understanding of reality in the past
when you use language the kind of
language you use radically changes how
you think of reality for instance the
reason they do the pronoun battle is if
I hear about a transgender girl beats a
girl at a high school track meet I think
okay well a transgender girl who is a
type of girl
beats a different girl who's another
type of girl it attract me that seems
fair right but if I use accurate
language and I say a boy in a dress
beats a girl at a high school track meet
I'll become aware of the injustice of
that because men are physically stronger
than women and they're faster than women
say oh that's not fair that's wrong I
don't think that boy in a dress should
be able to take a scholarship away from
a girl and a girls track meet I think
the boy should compete with the boys and
the girl should compete with the girls
so they have to change the language
because if I just say she to refer to
the boy in the dress if I just say
transgender girl even though I am aware
of what that means I'm I'm explicitly
talking about that the image in my mind
is of a girl and that's what language
does he then goes on this city
councilman Rigel Robinson quote having a
male centric municipal code is
inaccurate and not reflective of our
reality women and non-binary individuals
are just as entitled to accurate
representation our laws are for everyone
and our Municipal Code should reflect
that here he's completely wrong it's not
male centric man can refer to a man like
me or it can refer to mankind which is
gender-neutral in the book of Genesis it
reads God created man , both male and
female he created them
male and female of man because we're
talking about mankind when the Apollo 11
astronauts landed on the moon Neil
Armstrong said one small step for man
one giant leap for mankind is that
there's that distinction there between a
man which is Neil Armstrong and man
referring to mankind you don't have to
say humankind you don't have to say
people kind man can be gender-neutral as
well but the singular day by the way the
singular they already exists when people
say instead of saying hey call your
friend see if they want to come hang out
people already use this and we do it
because we're so timid about sex in our
society because you know that if you say
something that is true but politically
incorrect like referring to a man who
thinks he's a woman as a man you will be
kicked off of Twitter you violated the
rules if you're in school you'll be
called into the principal's office if
you're at work you'll be called into HR
so we use they not because it's correct
or grammatical but because it's just
easier it's just easier for us not to
have to fight the they suggests many
other things it suggests among them that
there is no difference between the sexes
he or she just day is fine it suggests
maybe there are more than two biological
sexes Robinson in his in his line he
referred to non-binary people non-binary
now there there are people who are
hermaphrodites or intersex who have
ambiguous genitals or even ambiguous
chromosomes that those people represent
at most 0.05 percent of the population
0.05 percent 99.95 percent of the
population is either male or female but
if we alter our language to only focus
on the 0.05 percent rather than the
99.95% we create the impression that
many if not most people are non-binary
which is just a bizarre fiction and it's
this particularly leftist fiction and
it's a particularly liberal fiction and
it's a particularly modern fiction the
story of modernity is the story of
emancipation liberation that's that's
what we talk about that everybody talks
about that we emancipate ourselves from
all forms of oppression and this
initially means political oppression
oppression which one perceives from a
king let's say then it's emancipating
yourself from social oppression the
oppression of your town or your
community or your family even then it's
it's emancipating yourself from moral
oppression don't slut-shame me don't
don't shame me I'm going to embrace
pride I'm going to I'm going to deny the
existence of a moral law because if
there's a moral law than someone's
telling me what to do and that's
oppressive this now comes down to a
natural emancipation and emancipation
from the natural biological sorts of
oppression we're trying to emancipate
ourselves from our very nature not just
aspects of human nature like our
fallenness our brokenness our greed our
ambition our envy or our over ambition
rather but actually from our biology
saying I am NOT even to be oppressed by
my own body even my own body oppresses
me we're emancipating ourselves from
ourselves and ironically this means
emancipating ourselves from all
distinction all variety all diversity
nobody can be there can't even be men
and women everybody has to be the same
and it only leaves this boring and
ironically oppressive sameness
homogeneity it's just all exactly the
same this is the totalitarian vision
this sameness this is what's imagined in
every dystopian novel in every dystopian
vision people are all kind of we're just
wearing grey they all kind of look the
same they all speak the same if you
contradict the totalitarian regime
you're liquidated you're taken out you
can't you just have to say the same
things think the same things look
exactly the same way and it's no
surprise that Berkeley California left
of Lenin is leading the charge in its
language speaking of language we got to
get some mailbag questions coming in but
first listen up all of you truth loving
cigar smoking whiskey drinking seekers
of laughs and insight because this is
for you we are taking backstage on the
road backstage live August 21st to the
terrace theater in Long Beach Cal
fornia ben shapiro daily wire god-king
jeremy boring Andrew Klavan end you were
as truly your humble host will be live
on stage discussing the winners and
losers of politics and pop culture and
doing our best to answer your burning
questions from the audience and we'll be
selling merch and by we I mean there's a
very good chance they're gonna make me
just work at the merch booth so tickets
are available at daily wired.com slash
backstage there were still a few VIP
ticket packages available which include
premium seating photos and meet and
greets with all of us a gift from me
much much more it's a lot of fun you
know I love meeting people on the road
at these college events but when we do I
think we're just doing one event this
year as The Daily wire these are the
best events of the year they are so cool
I love meeting people and I've actually
got you know if stayed in touch with a
number of people that I've met and it's
just one of the great opportunities for
us and I hope it's a great opportunity
for you so get your tickets bring a
friend bring some good questions and
come join us for a fantastic event go to
Daley wire comm right now we'll be right
back with the mailbag
all right the first question from Jonah
dear Erik's wawel what are your thoughts
on Facebook censoring a st. Augustine
quote and do you think that Facebook
will ever stop trying to censor
conservative and Christian voices
hashtag came for been stayed for Michael
Jonah aged 16 this is a story we
actually didn't get time to cover it
this week Facebook censor to quote not
from some awful bigoted not from even
some conservative political figure which
they try to do frequently they censored
a quote from one of the fathers of the
church and one of the greatest Saints of
history st. Agustin and this is the
quote let us never assume that if we
live good lives we will be without sin
our lives should be praised only when we
continue to beg for pardon but men are
hopeless creatures and the less they
concentrate on their own sins the more
interested they become in the sins of
others they seek to criticize not to
correct unable to excuse themselves they
are ready to accuse others that this is
obviously a true quote I mean this is
the essence of the Lord's Prayer forgive
us our trespasses as we forgive those
who trespass against us
it's the idea that you know before you
take the speck out of your brother's eye
you should pull the plank out of your
own eye obviously we're we're a culture
right now that that totally focuses on
everybody else's problems and ever on
our own we always judge everyone else in
their their actions we judge ourselves
on our intentions never on our actions
because then we have to admit that we
screw up all the time Facebook is not
going to stop doing that
Facebook is now in the business of
censoring the truth you cue social media
now will ban you if you state simple
facts men are not women there's very
very basic things and so they are
they're always going to come after the
truth if you don't celebrate pride I
mean what Christian wants to celebrate
pride it's the queen of all sins
deadliest sin so no they're not going to
stop it there they're going to go after
those people who state simple moral
truths I mean cry Christ told us this
you said that we will
be hated for his sake and it's actually
a good thing to be hated for his sake
look what they did to him
obviously the culture not just this
culture but all cultures all all human
society is in some ways going to
persecute followers of Christ and this
is just another example of that and I
can't believe it but they're going after
Saint Agustin what seventeen hundred
years after the man lived that's I guess
to be expected from Brett
greetings Kofi a sensei if a man
receives a gender reassignment surgery
hormone therapy plastic surgery and a
successful functioning uterus to carry
children do they have a legitimate claim
to say that they are a woman no I guess
we can end the question there no they're
not they resemble women in some ways
they function like women but they are
not women and what we're confusing is a
kind of utilitarian functional
definition of what a woman is to what
sex actually means so women aren't just
sort of machines and vessels for bearing
children they're not just instruments
for our own pleasure I mean these days
we treat them that way that's what the
surrogate movement is all about is
basically paying desperate women to
carry our babies because we don't want
to do it ourselves or we can't do it
ourselves but that's not what when women
are not just instruments for our own
desires women are human beings with
equal dignity that's why the the sexual
difference between men and women comes
in the first few chapters of Genesis
it's why the sexual difference between
men and women is the essence of the
story of Gilgamesh and other
foundational story of human nature it's
why it's true of every veinte tional
story of mankind sexual difference is
foundational to who we are and speaking
of Genesis it's why women are plucked
the eve is plucked from Adam's rib she's
not plucked from his head she's not
superior to Adam she's not plucked from
his feet she's not inferior to Adam
she's plucked from his rib she has equal
dignity to Adam and you can't change
that you can't change your sex which is
so foundational it is it is a part of
who you are
you can't just change it by getting
cosmetic surgery you can't even just
change it by turning yourself it's in
some scientific future into a plausible
vessel for carrying children it goes
deeper than that I mean the scientific
example today would be it goes down to
our chromosomes and spiritually and
metaphysically that tells us just how
essential sexual differences even to our
spirit from Joshua what are some
musicals that you have enjoyed I find it
more difficult these days to find non-pc
ones yeah musicals these days are pretty
pretty bad I don't really go see many my
favorite musical is Guys and Dolls one
of the all-time great musicals you
probably well speaking of gender
difference you probably can't even do
that today because it suggests that
there are such things as Guys and Dolls
but I loved it it was the first musical
I ever did when I was a kid I I'll let
you guess which role I played and it's
just one of the great ones you know and
there's a great film adaptation of it
with Marlon Brando and Frank Sinatra and
it takes place in New York there's
wonderful music to it it's fun it's not
trying to be more than it is these days
musicals tend to have this kind of PC
social justice aspect to them but that's
because musicals are dead so musicals
really thrived in the middle of the 20th
century we think of all those great
musicals of the 40s through the 60s and
then they kind of died I mean there's
some good ones since then but just just
not very many and it's true of the
movies you know there were great movies
and then the movies died and now the
movies are all just regurgitating
ideological messages art forms are born
they rise and they die and that's what
happened to musicals from Tony do you
think that President Trump has a punk
rock appeal that is going to help the
conservative movement win the younger
generation Tony he does in a certain
sense Millennials hate his guts
I noticed that gen Z seems to like him a
little bit more than Millennials do
because Gen Z is cooler than Millennials
he does have a punk rock appeal and that
he's contrarian he bucks the pop culture
he bucks what all of the scolds of the
mainstream media and the mainstream
culture telling him to do so I think
that's that's cool I don't know that
it's going to win him young voters too
a though I think it's gonna win him
young voters retrospectively you know
I'm old enough to remember when George
Bush was Hitler
now everyone longs for George Bush all
the Democrats love George Bush I mean
they they did call him Hitler they drew
swastikas over his face and gave him
little mustaches when he was in office
but now he's a great guy and I'm old
enough to remember when they did that to
John McCain and when he was running for
president and and failed to win and so
they're doing it to trump now in the
future though people are gonna cool off
and they're gonna realize that Trump
wasn't Hitler and then we're gonna look
at the history of it and we're gonna see
that things really did pretty well under
President Trump as far as all the
evidence we have right now things are
doing great the economy is doing great
our diplomatic relations are doing great
much better than they were under Barack
Obama things are pretty good overall and
and I think that the punk-rock appeal is
gonna be in retrospect we're gonna say
man that guy didn't listen to what all
the egghead experts were telling him and
he did it his own way and he listened to
the American people and he respected
them and things turned out better and
it's in many ways how Ronald Reagan
became a saint when Reagan was in office
a lot of conservatives didn't like him
you know Bill Buckley liked him at the
National Review but a lot of the rest of
that kind of self-appointed conservative
movement intelligentsia didn't really
care for him I mean they would they
would joke there some people put on the
door of the RNC in 1984 draft Bush
because they didn't want Reagan to even
run again and in retrospect though
because Reagan in in many ways like
Trump bucked the establishment bucked
established norms and and most
importantly because he was successful he
became a model of what a Republican
should be and what a Republican should
behave like with regard to the
mainstream culture so I could see that
happening with Trump we're just gonna
need a few years after he leaves office
for that to settle in from Blake Michael
as a published author on democratic
politics in your expert opinion who do
you think will pick up Beto's zero point
zero percent of the vote when he drops
out thanks Blake great question because
Beto's polling numbers have a lot in
common with the word count of my book a
reasons to vote for Democrats at
comprehensive
Gide both of those word counts are they
thoroughly describe the appeal of bado
and of the Democratic Party so I I
suspect that his 0.0% is going to go to
Eric's wall well obviously he's my
preferred candidate and I actually think
that 0.0% has already gone to Eric's
wall well so I think that prediction
also was correct from Braden hi Michael
I have friends that I shared daily wire
episodes with and they listen and they
say back to me that some of it they
agree with but much of it is opinionated
statements that aren't based on facts
they say you don't mention truthfully
what the other side really thinks
acknowledging what the more moderate
Democrats the ones that don't get media
attention or saying what do you think
about this thanks Braden well those are
two criticisms so you've got to separate
them out on one they're saying that that
what I say isn't based on facts and then
the second criticism is that I don't
show the more moderate Democrats so for
the first one when they say that to say
what you're saying isn't based on facts
it's very simple you you should ask them
to refute what I'm saying now part of
what I suspect their confusion is is
that they don't know what an opinion is
cuz a lot of people don't know what
opinions are people think that there are
facts which are factual and then
opinions which are not factual but that
isn't true there are facts which are
factual there are opinions which are
statements of fact from an individual's
point of view and then there's a third
category called preferences right like I
prefer vanilla ice cream to chocolate
ice cream here's an example two plus two
equals four that's a fact I think that
two plus two equals four that's an
opinion I prefer chocolate ice cream to
vanilla that's a preference it's not
based on a fact it's based on my own
taste and about taste there can be no
disagreement there can't be arguing so I
think people confuse that a little bit
and just ask them what the facts ask
them well what fact do you have that
refutes what these shows say as for not
showing the more moderate Democrats I
think we do that I mean I think we when
George Schultz was running
office when he was briefly running for
president I I showed that a bunch and I
said here are some of the Democrats but
here's why they're being overshadowed I
actually this whole week I've been
talking about how the more moderate and
I put that in quotes because the
Democratic Party actually objectively
has moved much further to the left so
there aren't really that many moderates
anymore there used to be what we're
called Blue Dog Democrats conservatives
now there are only a handful of them
like joe Manchin from West Virginia but
even relatively because moderation is
relative Nancy Pelosi and Joe Biden now
represent the kind of moderate wing of
the party and AOC and the squad
represents the radical wing but we've
been talking about that disagreement all
week so I just don't think that's a very
fair criticism of the show if they think
that there there is some huge number of
so-called moderate Democrats out there
and just accidentally very few of them
are if any are running for president and
none of them are or dominating the
political conversation please feel free
to show me that huge number of moderate
Democrats I haven't seen them from Grant
hey Michael I recently read CS Lewis's
the Screwtape Letters and I thought it
was a good start for my girlfriend to
learn about Christian morals turned out
she didn't quite understand it is this
the right literature for that purpose or
can you recommend something more
digestible keep up the great work thanks
coincidentally I'm actually rereading
the Screwtape Letters right now and it's
it's one of the the great books it's
written as this series of letters from a
demon from a little devil Screwtape to
his nephew wormwood and so he's talking
about all the different ways that these
devils and demons can go out and steal
the souls from God now obviously it's
it's written ironically I mean it's you
know he's easy
he's exposing what the Christian
worldview is from the negative which i
think is a really great and creative way
to do that but you know it doesn't work
for everybody so if it doesn't work what
I would recommend is a CS Lewis's other
book probably the most famous book Mere
Christianity I think that's just a
fabulous introduction to Christianity
it's not terribly humorous it's not
terribly create
I mean it just it really gives a pretty
basic introduction to Christianity and
it's very compelling and it's
theologically very advanced but it can
also be read by a three-year-old so I
recommend that but I also highly
recommend Screwtape and that's why I'm
reading it rereading it again right now
all right we got more questions but too
bad our show's over head on over to the
daily wire you know one thing I would
recommend too or I would ask of you is
if you would please go to Apple podcasts
and subscribe to the Michael an old show
we appreciate that that helps that helps
us you know keep track of the audience
and make sure that you don't miss one
single minute of this show so check all
that out have a good weekend
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see on
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
we're gonna discuss tribalistic
demagoguery which is a plague in our
society and it is leading us down a dark
path I believe our leaders on both sides
many of them are nothing but tribalistic
demigods and they seem eager to
encourage radicalism chaos civil unrest
so we'll discuss that also Scarlett
Johansson has run afoul of the PC mob
and finally a feminist devised one of
the possibly may be the dumbest
invention of all time we'll discuss that
also today over on the wall show